welcome to the GOP debate on CNBC where
facts don't matter and respect is not
expected I am a gentleman with a Latin
American sounding name candidates you
will all be given precisely 30 seconds
to answer your questions and if another
candidate mentions your name at any
point you will be given 15 seconds to
respond at which point you must both
enter a racquetball court but only one
leaves it's a new format and we're
pretty excited about it here first
question to mr. Trump you've been seen
as bombastic douche-baggy and as overall
hostile to the minority community
oh you're worth your thoughts
all right truthfully okay that's a very
real question to start with I'm a little
surprised you know listen it's almost a
surprising it affected that John Kasich
is over there still shut up you shut
your mouth nobody wants to hear from you
okay
people often ask do I pick on people at
the back it's because I know they can't
hit back listen frankly minorities love
me okay
I get so many Mexicans all the time
coming up to me tell me we love you plan
we love you pledge so much we just we
want us we want to have more plants that
come from Trump and frankly okay they
call me the black machine with how many
votes I'm gonna get for the blacks okay
that's what they call it let's down what
I would call myself that's what they
call me they call me the black machine
dr. ben Carson would you care to respond
well listen I think that mr. Trump has
injected some some new life into the
into the process I don't agree with him
on everything I think that what he just
said was borderline functionally
[ __ ] respectfully oh I'm getting in
my ear that your mic I'm sorry mr.
Carson could you repeat that your
microphone was not on now I'm quite
confident that my microphone is holy
crap you are right it is still on mr.
Trump would you like to respond rightly
I need some blacks in my cabinet I need
some blacks in my cabinet and you know
dr. ben Carson listen Barack Obama is
kind of middle-of-the-road you know
listen he's sort of sort of if you put
some half at a fat your milk and guitar
you get Barack Oh
but you're talking about a guy okay all
right truthfully dr. ben Carson true I
say this with respect what people say
that you're not black enough because you
know you're running for the GOP okay
this guy over here he was raised in
Detroit
to a single mother okay that's got
triple a ball he's played for the MVPs
over there okay as a black guy frankly
mr. Carson moving on to another question
you were once caught buying a rotisserie
chicken at Costco which has been rated
as one of the most gay friendly
businesses by the Better Business Bureau
do you find that to be staggeringly
hypocritical i buy the chickens because
they're $4.99 and even for a brain suit
and that's the deal that i can't pass up
are you serious with these questions
okay frankly don't answer that dr. ben
Carson okay to try to trap you here they
try to trap you with some kind of a
racial stereotype with Costco and
chicken it's disgusting
okay and that's exactly why I didn't
want to give CNBC more dubbers with a
three-hour debate with your ratings that
and the fact that my doctor shows they
gave out about two and a half hours they
give out about two an ephah
i love doctor they call me the doctor
Scholl's machine all right next question
comes from my qualified colleague Becky
hey guys okay so you're running for
president right yes that's a fact yes
I'm trying okay so most of you have like
a lot of money right yes a very rich
I've been well financially yeah okay
okay so like do any of you want to buy
some Mary Kay okay the brain stirred and
I'm quite sure that lady's functionally
[ __ ] what are the rules before we go
any further and just discussion we're
pretty much is making them up as we go
guys ever thought I'd say this but
frankly can we get megan kelly the [ __ ]
back in here okay this next question is
for mr. John Kasich Kasich kasitch
casick Kasich is a kasi oh you're out of
time next question for Trump if you were
a comic book villain who would you be
well frankly nobody okay because Trump's
a hero
all right frankly I would be so good at
being hero so well put down Joker mr.
Carson
moving on you were the first
neurosurgeon to separate
conjoined twins but I haven't here that
you also killed a baby 30 seconds to
respond of course that's not sure why
seriously it's his microphone on listen
I don't know about the black guy over
there okay but I frankly I love babies
I listen frankly and what always talks
about a trump presidency how good I'd be
for the economy how good I'd be for for
China okay but nobody talks about they
forget if I were president I would be so
good at babies okay frankly truthfully I
would be the best at babies if you like
babies you vote for Trump all right
final question and this one is for Miss
Carly Fiorina when running against
Barbara Boxer you had breast cancer in
becoming a warrior against Ted cancer
you had a double mastectomy and had your
breasts redone rumored to be Bionic
boobs do you feel that gives you an
unfair advantage in this election your
bionic boobs stay tuned for more of the
GOP debate coming up we'll find out if
ben Carson has had a stroke and ask
Carly Fiorina about her Barren womb here
on CNBC hey pansexuals watch a lot of
Miley Cyrus lately who she's so edgy
hope you enjoyed this video subscribe by
punching my face with the mouse that's
kind of cathartic or hit the button that
actually has subscribe written on it
maybe it's down here watch one of these
other videos they're all free they're
not as free as Miley Cyrus's spirit
though bird fly fly away